hmm I'm Bobby Thompson and let's get to  Steinitz short back it Saints and by  conceits Marley's always been born  oh of course it's not only we won't I  give me power Barney you hang over the  customers like a haunted scene has  changed  I saw that suddenly I've my very own  one-to-one copper buddies into money  I'll be taking inspector a little G with  a large person to talk to miss doing  this you feel guilty even though you've  never done anything wrong what no more  I'm gonna have to fish atmosphere it's  also this line he's hiding something  Barney Thomson is that sound like a  please feed your killer are you  you don't even know where the bodies are  you chop them up easily believe I label  everything  what is some conspiracy  give me a lift to the valleys it for  bingo night more I cannot a much the key  busy  hear me it's my bed good night boys  [Music]